what does it feel like to have this this
fame at this time for you guys the last
you know since we've been together we
know we didn't expect any of this to
happen so for it to happen so quick like
we've only been together like not even
two years yet is it no not even two
years yet so like you know we it all
happened so fast for us so we don't you
know we just kind of go with it we don't
really deal with it or like you know
people always say so how do you deal
with all this we kind of we just kind of
go with it like every day is different
then we we enjoy the different things
and stuff so really it's not bad that's
kind of like creamy stuff last but said
but it tastes kind of creamy really ice
cream la creme you love a cream you
honor it is that for some people who
don't know um x-factor played no you
know heart obviously in your careers
talk a little bit about how it all
started you were all solo artists when
this all began and take us on the ride
and tell us a little bit about how that
all came together so basically we all
auditioned as solo artists on the UK
version of The X Factor we all got to to
the bootcamp stage which is the final
two enjoys must tune evolve uh-huh
that's 24 boys do you forget that yeah
okay that's what written there was
clicked all right and then we've got
through to the last 24 bodies and then
we got told that we weren't going
through to judges houses I solo artists
so we were all ready to leave gar
suitcases ready to go just about to get
out the door and then they called us
back and said that they wanted to do
some like extra interviews and stuff so
we came back to the stage area and then
they called us back onto the stage
and Simon Nicole Scherzinger and the we
washed holders that they wanted to put
those five together in the group and in
the beginning when someone tells you I
mean you all came in solo artists you
all are talented in your own right and
some
you know what no I don't think that
works I'm gonna put you together did you
all say yeah yeah let's do this or
naturally were you a little bit yeah
sure
curled taking it way you know photos
like at that stage like you enter the
competition to get as far as you can
yeah I think you know it was kind of
like you go home as a solo I so you
continue in the competition as a group
you know it was really exciting overseas
our trouble honestly can we get a
close-up
try not to be rude so I tried to hide it
from everyone in it just floats on your
mount opposite Bob it to the bottom I'm
sorry I reckon this is going to be tasty
[Music]
so in the beginning it was a little bit
you guys weren't sure and then you start
to see each other's personalities not
the whole time is just really excited
and enhancing there's a new thing and
we're all kind of round to go and then
you know we're obviously from different
parts that comes in I like to can fly of
my later when we first started talking
about when we're gonna practice we're
kind of like how are we oh you know it
was good and your personalities are
different yet you all seem to carry a
great sense of humor yeah clearly that
was that something that kind of blended
really easily for you guys right off the
top yeah I think because most day that
we really yeah we kind of just like kind
of fitting title role sort of in the
band like we all know where we kind of
stand in the band where our places in
the band on how we work with each other
and stuff so yeah we all know our own
little things and why it works
so when you say everybody stands in band
what's that mean like say Louise the
Joker the band
the cute Irish go the band
Zayn's despoja mysterious man ooh
mysterious and Harry is the curly guy
who's very cheeky and likes women we all
like women
and you take care of Riza sensible and
sensible one and said that was kind of
established right off the top of surely
yeah that's fantastic
now musically you guys put your album
together what 2011 is that right
yeah that and then everything happened
really fast
did you have a big say and how the music
was gonna go we were really looking
actually because obviously like salmon
said to us when we were on the show and
stuff that he wanted just to be the band
that we wanted to be so we kind of took
that on board and then when you got to
you know making the music stage like
being in the studio and stuff we were
quite lucky we had you know a lot of
saying like lyrics and stuff and we
co-wrote on you know some of the songs
in the album and yeah so it was really
there's a really good time for me and I
thought it stood on the own favorite
song
mine is one thing me too one thing kind
of change though is often they're like
yeah yeah the limited edition some cool
moments about you alright mine's more
than this and musical influences you all
you love Michael Buble Canadian guy yeah
what do you love a bit of so much I
thought I just think he's such a natural
performer he's got a great voice
he looks good super nice guys it was
really really nice going hey man we've
met he's been really welcoming stuff so
and yes you know he's just cool
favourite Michael Buble saw things good
on that um maybe I like lost loss is
just the cost is a chance aggressive
yeah he's bad
so you guys have this huge amount of
fame in the UK in the US and in Canada
how do you deal with that I mean you you
go on the web be going YouTube or
anything that you guys with girls or
friends who people assume they're your
girlfriends does that make it tough for
you or are you are right with it I think
we just kind of really like embrace it I
think we're just having a good time we
know we're just teenaged lads having fun
yeah get all these girls like talking to
something internet stuff for meatless
and you know it's green stuff is like I
don't know we're just having a good time
I suppose yeah I mean we got a lot of
Twitter questions from people they want
to know who's Dave no single huh so most
straight you're single then - oh god
we've been meeting alright so is it hard
to date is it is it do you have time out
of it kiss yeah no I think you know if
you I guess like I think we live we live
kind of our lives right now like so
publicly like me with ever since I think
you know having that part of your life
being able to keep it kinda private
no I think just like I said you know we
kind of live everything everything's
kind of out in the open and now have
you know it's nice to try and keep that
baby private kids yours yes yeah you're
right and you're in you're able to do
that in a relationship right now yeah
yeah yeah I mean initially when everyone
like initially when everyone finds out
like there's obviously a tension
surround it then but like people kind of
more let's get used to you know yeah all
right cool when we did when we were
doing the signings if it airs I have a
lot of girls coming to your saying on
the end and whatnot and stuff so then
like say nice things they give them
bracelets and stuff that's were yeah
funds are amazing yeah